susana tiene 96 minutos para completar
un examen en la escuela
el examen comienza a la 1 59 pm y susana
tiene prácticas de voleibol a las 4 pm
cuánto tiempo tendrá susana al término
de su examen y al inicio de sus
prácticas de voleibol y pensemos un poco
en esto así que el examen comienza a la
159 lo cual es una hora muy extraña de
comenzar un examen pero bueno
hagámoslo así así que por aquí tenemos
una línea del tiempo donde esto de aquí
es las 2pm en punto y luego tendremos
las 3pm luego vienen las 4 pm en punto
donde también empieza aquí las prácticas
de voleibol así que aquí empezarán las
clases y más adelante vienen las 4 pm
donde empiezan las prácticas entonces
vamos a tener que el examen empieza a la
159 por lo que déjame extiendo un poco
la línea
entonces esto de aquí va a ser la 1 pm 1
pm en punto y como el examen comienza a
la 159 es un minuto antes de las 2 pm
pues como sabemos cada hora tiene 60
minutos y la 159 es un minuto antes de
las 2 y quizás no se note mucho pero por
aquí vamos a tener la 159 pm así que
usamos un minuto un minuto para que den
las 2 pm y luego ponemos entonces los 95
minutos que nos restan por tanto nos
tomamos otros 60 minutos por aquí para
llegar a las 3pm
entonces con estos serían 61 minutos
pues aquí ya hubo un minuto antes de las
dos y luego hay 60 minutos para que sean
las 3 pm y luego todo el camino para
llegar a las 4 pm son otros 60 minutos
que es más el tiempo de lo que yo tengo
para el examen y nosotros sabemos que en
total el examen dura 96 minutos por lo
que será aquí un punto como éste donde
serán los 96 minutos ahora necesitamos
imaginarnos cuáles son los minutos que
restan hasta esta distancia de aquí o
cuál es el tiempo o la diferencia del
tiempo que queda hasta este punto y para
ver esto tendríamos que ver el tiempo
que ha pasado desde el tiempo de
comienzo hasta los 96 minutos que es
donde acaba entonces a las 3 pm han
pasado 61 minutos y si decimos cuántos
minutos se dan después al finalizar el
examen van a ser 96 menos 61 lo cual son
35 minutos
esto de aquí estoy aquí va a ser las 3
35 pm lo cual ahora la pregunta en
cuanto al tiempo es qué tiempo hay entre
las 3 35 y las 4 pm y una vez más hay 60
minutos en una hora cierto y las 4 pm
son 60 minutos entonces tomamos 60 menos
35 lo cual nos da 25 minutos así que
ella tiene 25 minutos restantes después
del examen para llegar a las prácticas
de voleibol pues tuvo un minuto antes de
las 2 otros 60 para llegar a las 3 pm
van 61 y luego otros 35 para formar los
96 del examen y listo